and trying out airbnbs on the road you
got to read those listings very closely
they always start out good it's like on
a tree-lined street close to shops and
restaurants oh I like that
you'll have the whole place yourself oh
I like that I let my neighbors store his
guns in my linen closet
sure I feel about that
so he might pop in from time
I don't like that but don't worry as a
key oh that makes me worry
also there's a great home theater system
you're not allowed to use it stay out of
the kitchen
and there's a python under the sofa
you must feed him 15 times a day
but to reiterate you'll help the whole
place yourself
close to shops and restaurants
foreign